every year nevada has among the highest
rates in the entire country for domestic
violence
and that's been especially true during
the pandemic the last few months
now several groups are coming together
to raise awareness and joe muller is
joining us live now from the welcome
sign which has a much different look
this morning hi joe
hey there good morning alex well october
is the national domestic awareness
month and a lot of places building signs
are shedding light on the problem
literally by going purple now take a
look at the
welcome to las vegas sign those iconic
lights are flashing purple this morning
well last night five non-profit groups
came together to
talk about domestic violence and to
share information about the problem
like you mentioned nevada is already
known to have one of the highest rates
of domestic violence for both children
and adults
for the first six months of 2020 the
need for services
has increased dramatically there has
been a 42 percent increase in both
children and adults seeking beds at
shelters and also a 42 percent increase
in calls to violence hotlines nonprofit
organizers say the pandemic has had a
major
impact on domestic violence during covid
we've seen our domestic violence rates
go
way up so we're raising awareness so
that folks understand there are
resources here
that they can get help and support they
don't need to live in a dangerous
household
while the need is greater than ever
during the pandemic the amount of
donations for this
is actually down a number of buildings
in las vegas have been going purple
throughout the month and some still
are so if you're wondering why things
are looking a little purple this is why
now this morning on my drive into work i
also noticed the world market center has
gone purple
as well now nonprofit organizers who
were here last night did talk about how
you at home can also shed light on the
problem
by wearing purple whenever you can and
to also maybe change a light in front of
your house to purple to get the
conversation going about this now there
are some resources out there for people
who are facing problems
we do have a link and a hotline number
up on our website just click on this
story
just head to eightnessnow.com reporting
live here on the las vegas stream joe
mullen 8 news now